hey guys Pete here could be my mr. robot
season 3 episode 4 recap and review a
sort of quiet episode for this season as
far as what the pace has been but I
think it's a pretty important one table
setter table setting episode I guess you
could say but some pretty important
stuff got laid out for us here at the
end of it all I thought that it was
certainly a Darlene centric episode I
have to say it felt a little bit like it
might be a goodbye to Darlene but we
really don't know that's just
speculation I guess but it was a deeper
look at how all of this is taking a toll
on her I think that it's a little bit
surprising actually how much we kind of
understand where people hurt at this
point based on previous seasons I don't
think it's a bad thing but we're season
two kind of subverted that expectation
of us understanding what was going on at
all times this sort of seems to have
gone back the other way where we can be
kind of certain that what we see on the
surface is actually what's going on but
we know that Elliott is literally split
in two so we actually know what mr.
robots doing but he does not I think the
scene that kind of defined the episode
was probably the scene in the bar with
Darlene and Dom and we find out about
just how hard it is for Darlene to do
what she's doing she says she's gonna
lose her brother and like I said the
whole thing just kind of feels like
we're going to lose Darlene that she's
gonna be a casualty of this war but I
don't I don't know what you guys think I
don't know if it was just me but that's
that really came across as a real
possibility I think we did get some nice
shots of those two together though we
can see that she's working with him to
try to keep mr. robot in check they make
a vengeance pack which was kind of cute
and she legitimately feels awful about
the situation and she's trying to do
what she can she's you know she's
working with the FBI to stay out of jail
but she's also equally as committed to
trying to help Elliot at the same time
and she knows that she's going by
breaking his trust that she's going to
change their relationship and
that will never be repaired so yeah it's
actually really deep character study
here she betraying someone that she
loves she feels awful about it at the
same time she thinks she's doing the
right thing stopping the dark army but
she's gonna pay a huge price for doing
the right thing so I thought they laid
that out really well whenever she's
asking DOM personal questions you know
you can just sort of connect the dots
back to Darlene she also had some funny
moments in the episode and I don't want
to see her go I hope that that I'm wrong
about that feeling the big aha moment
though was that she in her watching of
Elliot saw Angela meeting with mr. robot
from that we find out that those two
have been working together with Tyrell
to get stage 2 ready which White Rose
has now moved up and that they have to
go on Monday but Elliot during the day
has been working counter to their goals
and making things difficult that brings
herbing into the mix he's there to push
Tyrell along build him up I think there
was some real foreshadowing here with
Tyrells anger again he has the tendency
to just start breaking things whenever
it's not knowing his way and the more
that they show that the more I feel like
that's gonna play a part later on down
the road
I mean Tyrell is pretty simple at this
point based on what we saw last week he
is trying to get his family back he's a
pretty straightforward guy in the way
that he operates he's doing this for
that reason only he doesn't know the
think Joanna's dead and it's pretty
clear that that's under wraps and he's
not gonna find out until after he does
what they want him to do at that point
he becomes rather expendable as well so
you gotta wonder how that's gonna play
out we do find out who the mysterious
character was in the trailer with the F
Society mask I mean we don't find out we
see the person this rub me as something
that White Rose set up based on the way
that he looked whenever the name
whiterose was spoken I think that yeah
it was just probably a distraction of
sorts I mean we talked about this in in
other videos like we didn't know who
that was
I don't think that he is anybody I think
he like I said I think he just seems
like a plant to me to serve some purpose
I don't think that anyone would be able
to pull off the video and all that but
at the same time get caught so easily as
Dom sort of pointed out we get a quick
bit of Phillip price here Angela needs
to go to him directly he says that he'll
fire Elliot
that's what Angela wants him to do I
wonder if he will do that or not or if
he will just do it without thinking I
mean that seems pretty unlikely right
he's in he's at war with whiterose right
now he knows that white rose has control
on some level of Angela and now he knows
that angela has called him on the phone
and asked him to do something so he'll
probably look into that a little bit
closer the Angelus stuff is pretty
full-blown at this point she is I would
assume that she still just driven by the
desire to get revenge for her mother
it may have morphed into something
different at this point in this episode
it's interesting to look at the contrast
of these two people who Elliot trusts
more than anyone else
his sister Darlene and his best friend
from childhood Angela
they're both betraying him different
ways but in a major kind of I mean
they're not just lying to him about
something small here they're they're
definitely manipulating his reality I
don't know how to better explain that so
on the one hand you have Darlene who's
trying to do it for what is the best
reason even though it's not acceptable
it wouldn't be acceptable and then on
the other hand you have Angela who you
know it just kind of feels like I don't
know I mean I think the but I guess the
best analog is you know the religious
fanaticism we don't really know enough
to describe it but she's operating on
this level of she has a purpose she's
found that sane and everything else
looks worth it at the end does that make
sense like you know she was going to
betray her best friend she's
shooting him up with drugs when he comes
back so that he goes back out and she
can manipulate his dark side I mean
that's actually what's going on right so
it's interesting to see how there is a
big difference there but it all comes
down to Elliot who has a history of not
being able to keep it together
being betrayed in unthinkable ways by
both of the people that he trusts at the
same time and I think that that's pretty
key that he started to come back
whenever they were in that room and
we're gonna see how that goes from here
on out now the floor of the season aired
they gave these out to people the whole
season the watch and then they wrote
their spoiler free things and everyone
that I read had mentioned that Episode
five was gonna be a game-changer and I
think we saw how there's a set up here
and I'm pretty I'm pretty good with it
it was a good episode it wasn't as
exciting as the last few but it was it
hits some good points and I am and I
hope I'm wrong about the feeling that I
got about Darlene exiting the storyline
because I really enjoyed what we saw in
this episode I mean obviously we don't
learn all the episodes to be like this
but her character got a lot more depth
to it and I would hate for that just to
be an introduction to her and I think
Dom has an episode coming up I mean
that's what it feels like to me she's
just sort of been on the periphery the
whole time this season she got called
out a little bit for playing the pronoun
game by Darlene and it just made me
think that she's in a similar kind of
situation with her work in that SantaCon
Tiago is working with the dark army so I
feel like she's gonna have a crossroad
of like faith or whatever at some point
and I feel like there's a domme episode
in the works at some point so that we
can find out more about what's going on
with her all right that's it I don't
want to just ramble on all day let me
know what you thought about the episode
in the comments please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already make sure
you turn on notifications by hitting a
little bell so you'll know when the next
video comes out follow me on Twitter
Instagram or Facebook
interact with me over there thanks for
watching guys I'll talk to you soon